Ombre brisée
Downie les
bas-fonds, les bas-fonds grandissent jusqu'à ce que nous sortions,
oui, oui, si vous descendez St, tournez
à droite et montez les escalators et sur votre
droite
[Musique], c'est le
roi, c'est les deux derniers et il
n'y aura pas de  ne faites pas la fête avec la météo et
grenouille le moins profond RS le moins profond RS
le F allez le F
dehors le moins profond pousse le moins profond R
le F allez
dehors en nous dirigeant vers le fond, nous
[Musique]
glissant le
grabit oh
merci, prends une
[Musique] c'est vrai, c'est la
place
5330 150 est-ce que ça
marchera
200 I I Je sais que j'en avais l'air en
ce moment I mais je ne suis pas une
prostituée tu sais que c'est mieux pour
[Musique]
ça